T
PERISH FOR NOTHING.
HONOR THEIR SACRIFICE.
REMEMBER THAT EVERY DAY AS
MEMORIAL DAY.
JOINING US WITH A MEMORIAL DAY
MESSAGE, COMBAT VETERAN
JONI ERNST.
GREAT TO HAVE YOU WITH US THIS
MORNING ON "FOX & FRIENDS."
WHAT IS YOUR MESSAGE ON
MEMORIAL DAY?
>> YES, IT IS EXACTLY WHAT
MR. CARPER SAID.
WE SHOULD REMEMBER THE FALLEN
TODAY.
WE HAVE SO MANY FAMILIES THAT
ENJOY THE DAY OFF FROM WORK,
SCHOOL AND OTHER ACTIVITIES, BUT
WE HAVE TO REMEMBER THE ESSENCE
OF THE DAY AND THOSE WHO GAVE A
SELFLESS SACRIFICE, THE ULTIMATE
SACRIFICE FOR THE FREEDOMS WE
ENJOY EVERY SINGLE DAY.
SO PLEASE TAKE TIME OUT TO
REMEMBER THOSE WHO HAVE FALLEN
FOR ALL OF US.
>> Will: JACK CARR NOT JUST A
WRITER ON FoxNews.com BUT SOON
TO BE AT A MOVIE THEATER NEAR
YOU.
I WANT TO TALK TO YOU ABOUT YOUR
BILL THAT YOU HAVE PUT FORWARD
TO.
IT WILL USE UNUSED BORDER WALL
MATERIAL.
BEEN SITTING AND ROTTING NOW FOR
OVER A YEAR.
IT WAS NOT DEPLOYED.
THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION
ACTIVELY TOOK THIS BORDER WALL
MATERIAL OUT OF SERVICE.
YOU ARE PROPOSING A BILL TO PUT
IT BACK IN SERVICE AND ALLOW
STATES TO FINISH WHAT THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION STARTED.
TELL US ABOUT THIS BILL AND WHAT
YOU THINK YOU CAN ACCOMPLISH AND
WHETHER IT CAN PASS.
>> THANKS, WILL.
AND THEY DON'T REALIZE THAT
PRESIDENT BIDEN CALLED THE
BORDER WALL A WASTE OF MONEY!
AND YET, EVERY SINGLE DAY, THE
BIDEN ADMINISTRATION PAYING
CONTRACTORS UPWARDS OF
$3 MILLION TO BASICALLY BABYSIT
THE MATERIALS THAT ARE LEFT
LYING IN THE DESERT.
SO, MY BILL WOULD ALLOW STATES
TO TRANSFER THOSE MATERIALS FROM
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT TO THOSE
STATES IF THEY CONTINUE BUILDING
THE WALL ALONG THE BORDER.
THERE ARE A NUMBER OF STATES
THAT HAVE ALREADY INITIATED
THEIR OWN BUILDING, STATES LIKE
ARIZONA, TEXAS, AND IT'S SITTING
THERE UNUSED.
LET'S ALLOW THE STATES TO FINISH
THE JOB.
I DO HAVE A NUMBER OF REPUBLICAN
COSPONSORS, AND I ACTUALLY HAVE
A COUPLE OF DEMOCRATS AS WELL.
YOU CAN GUESS WHO THOSE
DEMOCRATS ARE.
THEY ARE THE ONES THAT ARE
ACTUALLY CONSIDERING THE BILL AS
WELL.
I WOULD LOVE FOR THIS BILL TO
PASS, AWAY FOR THE THINGS THAT
HAVE ALREADY BEEN PURCHASED BY
THE TRUMP ADMINISTRATION SITTING
THERE TOTALLY UNUSED BY THE
BIDEN ADMINISTRATION.
>> Will: I WOULD LOVE TO HEAR
THE REBUTTAL TO YOUR BILL
ARTICULATED.
EXPLAIN TO ME, NOT JUST TO ROT
BUT TO PAY IT TO BABYSIT WHILE
IT ROTS INSTEAD OF USING IT.
WE WILL SEE IF THAT MAKES IT TO
TH